i
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a corresponsales soy
herminia fernández por andrés espinal en
ucrania fue capturado el centro
ferroviario del imán por las fuerzas
rusas que cada vez están más cerca de
ese verdon y es un equipo de france 24
vivió de cerca las últimas horas de la
ciudad en manos ucranianas
estas imágenes muestran los últimos
momentos antes de que el imán cayera en
manos de las tropas rusas
mientras los soldados ucranianos
trataban de evacuar a tantos civiles
como fuera posible
y bajo un bombardeo casi constante
y con la prisa por salir los residentes
tienen poco tiempo para [__] sus
posesiones
que podemos llevar no nos queda nada
aquí nuestra madre ha muerto no hay
razón para quedarse
se dejan provisiones para los que
quieran quedarse a vivir bajo el dominio
ruso
unas horas más tarde las tropas
ucranianas huyen de la ciudad mientras
se retiran vuelan en el último puente
que une el imán con el territorio
ucraniano
rusia intensifica su ofensiva en el
donbass en estas imágenes satelitales el
terreno está plagado de agujeros de
proyectiles
esta ciudad es una de las próximas en el
camino de rusia la policía está yendo de
puerta en puerta para advertir a los
residentes que evacúen nadie debería
pasar por esto es aterrador dios mío es
aterrador a pesar de la caída del imán
el presidente ucraniano selenski sigue
insistiendo en que el donbass seguirá
siendo ucraniano cueste lo que cueste en
el norte de italia una fábrica que
trabaja conjuntamente con la siderúrgica
ucraniana s'hostal está actualmente
parada ya que el acero de ucrania no
puede llegar hasta allí pero justo al
lado una fábrica propiedad de un
oligarca ruso que utiliza acero ruso
está trabajando a pleno rendimiento y
además su producción ha aumentado en las
últimas semanas nuestra corresponsal
natalia mendoza fue a visitarlos y nos
cuenta más sobre esta guerra del acero
que tiene lugar en italia
desde el estadillo de la guerra estaba
sería del norte de italia está
paralizada la línea de producción está
cerrada y el horno está apagado desde
hace semanas la razón el acero que se
transformaba aquí venía de un cráneo el
acero que venía de mariupol se cocía en
ese horno de allí a 1200 grados hoy todo
se ha parado esta planta pertenece al
grupo propietario de la acería us hostal
en 2021 se procesaron aquí cerca de 700
mil toneladas de acero ucraniano este
año la última entrega salió de ucrania
el día antes de la invasión rusa desde
entonces nada sin embargo a unos cientos
de metros de aquí la situación es
radicalmente diferente en esta acería
ésta es la sucursal italiana de una
colosal empresa siderúrgica rusa
propiedad de un estrecho aliado de
vladimir putin aquí todo sigue igual
desde el comienzo de la guerra
toda la materia prima de allí viene de
rusia se entrega constantemente ahora
mismo estamos trabajando a tope porque
tenemos muchos pedidos importante como
es el 15 de marzo la unión europea
decidió prohibir la importación de
productos metálicos de rusia pero el
grupo ha conseguido eludir las sanciones
porque el 51 por ciento del negocio está
registrado en europa el nuestro están
aplicando nuestras sanciones pero en
este caso las sanciones no se aplican
porque los barcos que llegan de rusia
están registrados según la propiedad de
la empresa que aparece como europea y
eso permite que los barcos vayan y
vengan es una buena noticia para la
gente que trabaja aquí vende
a pesar de que la actividad continua
aquí todos los que trabajan en el sector
siderúrgico están de acuerdo esperan una
rápida resolución del conflicto en
ucrania para evitar consecuencias en la
industria siderúrgica un sector
estratégico que proporciona más de 70
mil puestos de trabajo en italia hace 4
años turquía era el país del mundo que
más te tenía reporteros aunque esta
situación había disminuido la presión
contra el periodismo independiente ha
comenzado a arreciar nuevamente a un año
de las elecciones presidenciales
conoceremos un poco de estos ataques a
los periodistas y medios en el siguiente
informe de adrià rocha y albert nada
cae la tarde y el informativo estrella
de la televisión turca hard tv está a
punto de empezar irfan de armenia y uno
de los presentadores de televisión más
reconocidos del país se prepara para el
programa él y sus compañeros realizan
uno de los informativos más vistos y más
combativos de turquía y por ello pagan
las consecuencias
cada día somos amenazados dos colegas de
la cadena recibieron una paliza en la
puerta de la televisión muchas ticos
sólo por lo que habían dicho por sus
palabras anchas picos de edwards
hace 4 años turquía al país del mundo
que más reportero se encarcelaba a la
situación ha cambiado pero la presión
sigue pero lóndero blue representante de
reporteros sin fronteras en turquía lo
sufre en carne propia está siendo
juzgado por supuesta propaganda
terrorista y podría ser condenado a 14
años de cárcel
tenemos un presidente que dirige
personalmente los procesos penales en
este país y que cambie el orden de todo
el sistema judicial por desgracia
la represión no obliga a muchos a buscar
alternativas y ese es el caso de yemen
week que fue despedida de una gran
televisión por criticar al presidente
turco ahora trabaja a través de youtube
donde concentra millones de seguidores
acosan primero en twitter y después
pasan a los medios convencionales y
televisiones leales al gobierno que
empiezan a señalar te a decir cosas
terribles sobre ti y sobre todo si eres
mujer siempre ponen una connotación
sexual para atacarnos con las elecciones
presidenciales programadas para dentro
de un año la presión contra los
periodistas aumenta
[Música]
ante la baja popularidad de erdogán
estos comicios se prevén históricos el
funk se prepara
este es el momento más importante de
nuestras vidas no tenemos mucho más
tiempo veremos quedan seis meses o años
para las elecciones y veremos qué pasa
podremos continuar haciendo las noticias
podremos continuar viviendo en turquía
veremos
si este presentador como muchos teme al
futuro a pesar de la presión el
periodismo independiente se esfuerza por
sobrevivir en turquía
[Música]
colombia celebrará una segunda vuelta de
elecciones presidenciales el próximo 19
de junio con el transfondo de un
incremento de la violencia en los
territorios más golpeados por el
conflicto y el abandono estatal veamos
el siguiente informe de marina sardiña y
lionel pusher y desde una de las
regiones más peligrosas para los líderes
sociales
antes de su asesinato salió una amenaza
firmada supuestamente por los
paramilitares donde salía el nombre de
miller y otros líderes amenazando los
supuestamente por el tema político
electoral posicionarse políticamente le
costó la vida al consejero indígena
miller correa uno de los 12 líderes
sociales asesinados en el departamento
del cauca colombia en lo que va de año
dura muñoz su compañera mantiene el
anhelo de un cambio a las amenazas
constantes da temor
que pueda repetirse la historia
pero pues
es ahí donde yo digo hay que hacer todo
lo posible todo lo que esté en nuestras
manos y más allá en los últimos cuatro
años la deriva para las comunidades
indígenas campesinas afro y
desmovilizados de las farc o el
incremento de la violencia en su contra
es observado aún más en las regiones
donde operan los grupos armados
respaldados por el narcotráfico los
cultivos ilícitos la minería ilegal el
acaparamiento de tierras y el abandono
estatal favianca mayo miembro de la
guardia indígena se recupera de un
ataque de las disidencias de las farc
que surgieron después del acuerdo de paz
de 2016 el mismo grupo asesinó a dos de
sus hermanos uno de ellos el popular
líder de la guardia indígena al medio
para mayo para el conflicto se agudiza
aún más dentro del territorio en el
gobierno de el presidente duque pues
hace como como a un lado deja la
dejación de los acuerdos de para no creo
que es más donde se incrementa el tema
de los cultivos de uso ilícito se
incrementa el tema de los grupos armados
y referente eso pues también se agudiza
el tema de la muerte de los líderes
sociales pese al dolor su madre evelyn a
mantiene la esperanza de que la paz se
refleje en todas las comunidades los que
votaron los que no votaron pero algunos
comuneros y entonces son unos como forma
de una familia y que toca que mirarse a
todos clemencia carabalí al líder está
feo feminista con más de una docena de
amenazas en su contra se siente por
primera vez representada en una
candidata surgida de las mismas
violencias y muchas liderezas padecen a
diario el ver que en medio de la labor
tan difícil que hacemos de un contexto
tan complicado
vemos que si se puede escuchar y
trabajar con las voces de los
territorios es lo que exigen al próximo
presidente colombiano estas comunidades
de las regiones más golpeadas por el
perpetuo conflicto armado son parte de
las voces en profundo descontento que
por primera vez en la historia podrían
llevar a un triunfo a la izquierda en
estos comicios
en perú hace más de 8 mil millones de
años se doméstico a la papa el alimento
de los legendarios incas los peruanos
celebran el día nacional cada 30 de mayo
nuestro corresponsal en lima francisco
zacarías viajo huánuco una de las
principales regiones productoras del
tubérculo de esa nación donde se rinde
homenaje a la ancestral patata
bien
como cada 30 de mayo los peruanos
festejan con orgullo el día nacional de
la papa y la mejor manera de hacerle
honor es comiendo el tubérculo en todos
los platos que la imaginación la
gastronomía y el paladar puedan inventar
si nosotros podríamos cambiarlos o
reemplazar el arroz o el pan lo
estaríamos haciendo por la papa sabiendo
que tenemos una infinidad de
diversidades de productos y platos que
podemos lograr con este producto
victoriano fernández participa en cada
feria que lo invita para mostrar las
distintas variedades de papa york
reuters nos ayuda con tu fue scarpa y
con fe reclaman kite sahuquillo pero en
el campo es donde pone su mayor esfuerzo
a través de un ritual de pago a los
ancestros le pide a los espíritus de los
incas que la cosecha sea buena este
campesino es descendiente de una
dinastía de agricultores y es dirigente
de los guardianes de papas nativas y
todavía nosotros pues seguíamos
utilizando nuestras nuestras
herramientas tradicionales que
antiguamente también los incas han
utilizado entonces eso es el mejor
legado que tiene y eso creo que es para
nosotros es un orgullo en 19 regiones
del perú más de 700 11 mil familias
productoras se sostienen gracias al
tubérculo de las 5000 variedades de
papas que existen en el mundo perú posee
más de 3500 y es el primer productor de
patata en latinoamérica algunos expertos
como sea el pfea obregón señalan que la
papa peruana es un producto de primera
calidad consideró que cero importación
de trigo
hice una importación de maíz no vamos a
morir porque porque la base de nuestra
alimentación está acá sin embargo el
consumo nacional y la exportación de
este año están comprometidos ante la
falta de 180.000 toneladas de
fertilizantes que se debían importar
desde rusia y ucrania para la siembra el
estado peruano invertirá más de 95
millones de dólares para afrontar la
crisis pero diversos especialistas creen
que no será suficiente el alimento más
importante del perú está en peligro
gracias por acompañarnos en
corresponsales también le damos el
agradecimiento a la librería mácula por
habernos cedido sus espacios para grabar
este programa siga con la programación
de france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Aplausos]